and I went to welcome to this video
playing we hunt summer yep do we get we
get for eatin we rarely play d 5 I
really wonder why do they all want to
play this somewhat boring stuff if I was
just better okay anyway of course this
is very solid end and playable nothing
wrong with it per se but I'm really
amazed how many people prefer this kind
of thing to do five I mean it just has
to be the better who so yeah anyway
let's see what do we get here Quintus is
so very early 95
no it's okay
while usually retreats the bishop to g3
and only then goes 95 so that he has f4
available here it's not so clear what is
doing next ninety-six i can actually
maybe take on a form yeah that's
possible um night each five you can take
on age seven so that I would do and this
is something to watch out for I don't
want to get them killed by a sacrifice
down
h3 okay maybe just for Bishop age 21
yeah I'm happy to do that I have gotten
rid of this bishop but it's one constant
Maria and now I think in the position is
roughly equal I wonder if I can do
something here maybe this and will be a
just something like that play for me
five maybe he's playing be three
actually okay so let's put this here so
that he has to consider this carefully
if he wants to play mmm the be porn
yeah I can take F 1 i'm not sure if this
is a good idea just why not why not
actually also get get gets me closer to
playing be five ok so here no but this
is probably better he still cannot play
b3 and anyway because he three hangs so
at the end I want to play b5 and tried
to play against the B porn and I'm
threatening I was threatening f6 they
have three
it doesn't have many squares and at
night just g4 at the moment every night
i cannot trap it
so I want to open the saab 9 f 5 is also
an additional thing that I have against
them against a form
I wonder if I should do this actually
just make it difficult for him to play
g3 oh I forgot about that one that
wasn't good that I should have prevented
probably maybe this is actually
interesting if I can provoke him to take
then F what is a tempo and if he covers
it I might be able to switch back to the
e-file here in this position I will know
that that's something I cannot pass ok
go back to the e-file nicer place would
be warned
he wants to play Queen to e5 here in
this position
3g five had still extremely solid
disposition you finish five shame yeah
it's probably probably just equal symbol
you too if I go look b6 no blundering
this then time I to do this and then
look to e7
ok certainly actually has screen f6 I
have no discovery
but be too now I can take me to now why
is he attacking actually him like age 5
or something okay i'm getting a bit too
slow here okay this should do the trick
white result that was still there always
sir always a little tricky a little bit
tricky it was Jim very very solid kind
of game Jim of course there's a slight
edge for black but can you win this is
the thing 95 I mean he should have done
that early am and never did Knight a5
hand before he can go to e three years
is stronger and now this kind of thing
it's a practice and maybe night h4
that's interesting that age 42 g6 I was
rather thinking about this hey it looks
very awkward but sure can you win them I
mean if you look at the engines line and
your own least use you see see only two
moves but I see a little bit longer like
11 moves it doesn't really matter how
deep it calculates him but just like you
seek shuffling yeah you don't see a
clear progress it looks fantastic for
black but how do you win that's not so
easy to do I'm not going to win be true
quickly
as we saw in the game I mean this was
better than than the game it this was
helping me other than I had got this one
in oh but why blinded the rook oh my god
I blonde the dog here oh that would have
been a bitter pill gay i blundered the
routine window oops I know everything
was back here back in order still not
much h5 is a draw Jim Jeff he can maybe
still draw with create which I clock had
expected it's very likely a draw okay
this is probably trading to cook to
total draw like here now can walk the
King awkward my point is not worth
anything it's probably it wrong yeah I
tap fine i mean this this kind of
positions say they are not very active
but tough to break down with him ok guys
thanks for watching